hello welcome thank you very much indeed
for swinging in by so I filmed in
hospitals uh many times I'm the Thomas
More I'm the the health course Health
correspondence science correspondent at
Sky News and
there were a lot of doctors who would
ask me what they should do and should
they put a stethoscope around their
necks and and I guess the reason is that
many people see that as The Stereotype
doctor the tool that every doctor has
but it's very different now we've got
virtual reality robotics uh we've got
Precision medicine and DNA and also
increasingly artificial intelligence
we've got here three Pioneers in their
field who are going to talk about some
of the developments in medicine and how
they're changing what doctors can do for
for us I guess
um and so starting here Mr awaz gilani
he's a neurosurgeon at Great Ormond
Street Hospital who used virtual reality
to successfully separate conjoined twins
whose brains were fused together we've
got Harris schwabe who's leading a
revolution in artificial intelligence at
guys and Thomas's hospital here in
London and on the far side Professor sir
Peter Donnelly CEO of genomics PLC which
is helping us understand what's written
in our DNA with the hope that we can
live longer and and live healthier
but let's start with you a ways Bernardo
and Arthur Lima three-year-old twins
fused at the brain
um and their parents in Brazil were told
there was no chance of of surgery so how
are you able to help
um it's the story of the Brazilian twins
I think was a good example of how
technology
has helped medicine in the past few
decades I mean we're extremely fortunate
that we live in the UK we're based here
in London one of the one of the hubs
Global hubs of this technology and we've
got the expertise and tools to do this
sort of work here help the children here
what we needed to do was to be able to
do this remotely in a different
continent and that's where a lot of the
technology the virtual reality platform
that we used came in
to we did a lot of the simulations these
surgeries can be quite complex with a
number of iterative steps and it's it's
quite important to run through the
simulations a number of times beforehand
so everybody knows what we're doing at
which stage and just normally you just
look at MRI scans and CT scans of of the
brain and those are brilliant they take
almost like bread slices through the
brain and and give you a very good idea
of what's going on all the way through
but they're still two-dimensional aren't
they and if you've got very complex
structures such as a fused brain then
that can be quite difficult for you to
envisage how you'll physically tackle
the surgery absolutely I mean with
conjoin twins what you have is two
brains twisted around each other so the
anatomy is very complex and to
understand that in your head which is
typically what surgeons would have to do
even for experienced people can be
rather you know almost an impossible
task what virtual reality augmented
reality helped us to do was for
ourselves is to understand much better
how these brains are entwined think
about the treatment strategies and not
only that then communicate that across
continents and that's really where the
power and the beauty of tech came into
what we did so how do then you you're
wearing VR goggles on both sides of the
Atlantic presumably but virtual reality
can bring you into the same operating
theater in in a sense so how do you then
start the operation and did you go down
one Avenue and then realize that was a
dead end that this was going to be a too
risky and then come back or how did it
work there was quite a bit of that so
um they send us all the data the CTS and
the MRIs the angiograms for the children
to London we put the data on our
platform so we have our own virtual
reality platform we wore the VR headsets
here in the team in Brazil were the VR
headset so we're all in the same virtual
reality theater and that's where we
started the simulations and should we do
it this way turn the head this way reach
a dead end as you've said Thomas and
then come back so we were able to refine
the whole journey in quite a lot of
detail before actually doing it in in
the flesh so to say which made the whole
experience much safer for the children
and much more comfortable for the
clinicians dealing with after 27 hours
we're going to have to speak up slightly
because of the the noise coming from the
cafes we just bear that in mind uh
um 27 hour operator
that's the last one I mean quite
remarkable that uh that it takes that
long but clearly
you had to proceed very slowly even
though you'd rehearsed the the operation
in advance that's absolutely right so
what we had expected was the surgery
should have taken us somewhere around 12
to 14 hours and it took us almost twice
that amount of time and that just goes
to show that whilst Tech has done a lot
in terms of what we can do at the moment
there's a lot more to be done our
predictions are still far from accurate
that's a really good point to to jump on
to to Harris when you're using AI at
guys and Thomas and Thomas's
how
how are we using daily
um in lots of different ways
um the main driver of course is the fact
that
we're in a
under-resourced Healthcare System and so
there's a constant driver to to improve
our throughput particularly with the
covert backlog
um and as well is to make sure that we
can raise and standardize the quality of
care that we're delivering so it doesn't
matter who sees you or where your scene
you'll get you're getting the best care
possible
Diagnostics is it are you training
training machines to to look at scans
and spot things that maybe the human eye
can't see or what so yeah so that's
where a lot of the work started
um and it's less about what the human
eye can't see but helping the human eye
see it quicker and more efficiently and
more consistently one of the first
um examples we had at guys to Thomas is
almost a decade ago was around pediatric
bone aging so these are children we come
in and we take their x-ray of their hand
and it's actually quite a
relatively boring task to assess how
well this patient is developing and
often we would have large backlogs of
these scans and that would lead to delay
in care and so we had uh deployed an AI
system where you would get a response
within seconds and that would allow
clinicians then to handle their care
appropriately we've now moved on to for
example reporting head CTS from the
emergency department so somebody comes
in on a Friday night they bump their
head and you want to know if there's
blood inside if they're bleeding and if
they need any acute intervention
um and typically there isn't a
consultant radiologist around there is a
registrar at glycember says there's one
Radiology registrar covering guys
hospitals and Thomas's and the Evelina
and so they're obviously very stretched
and
um this triage tour basically allows the
the radiologist registrar to prioritize
which Scan they look at first so we make
sure that the patients that need
intervention get seen a lot earlier
uh incredible and let's we'll talk about
how that works in in practice in a
minute but Peter I mean just explain
what what genomics is looking for he's
not looking for things like the Angelina
Joni uh Gene bracca uh one which has a
very strong risk for breast and ovarian
cancer for example you're looking for
much more subtle changes to the three
billion letters uh in the human genetic
code that's exactly right uh
up until now in healthcare genetics has
been about changes like the Angelina
Jolie mutation individual changes in our
DNA code which have a big impact on
people
now we've known for almost 50 years that
for all of the common diseases heart
disease and diabetes and breast cancer
and prostate cancer bowel cancer that
genetics is a big part of the story
about why some people are more likely to
get affected than others but we've
learned that it's not one change that
makes someone more likely to get heart
disease or diabetes it's many many many
changes in our DNA we've got three
billion letters in our DNA and there are
maybe a million of those that affect How
likely we are to get heart disease and
they're a different set of a million
that affect How likely a woman is to get
breast cancer and another set of a
million that affect How likely a man is
to get prostate cancer
and so over the last couple of years
we've learned about what these changes
are and we can measure them in people
so genetics is a big part of
susceptibility some men are 40 times
more likely than others to develop
prostate cancer just because of the DNA
they've inherited some women are 30
times more likely than others to develop
breast cancer for diabetes and heart
disease it's the same so what's exciting
in the area we focus on is that for the
first time now we can start to measure
that genetic component of risk for all
the common diseases it moves genetics
from an area which has focused on rare
diseases and been hugely successful to
actually impacting on all of the common
diseases something like 70 of the NHS
budget goes on those common diseases and
we can now learn person by person for
each one of us which one of those
diseases am I more likely to get and if
we do that we can identify people who
are at higher risk for those diseases
who are currently completely invisible
to the NHS
but the NHS has Pathways if you're at
higher risk for heart disease your GP
will recommend lifestyle changes and
have a conversation with you about
taking statins if you're at higher risk
for breast cancer there's a breast
screening program mammograms are offered
to women and so on so if each of these
diseases the NHS and and Healthcare
Systems around the world have Pathways
for people who are at higher risk it's
just that they haven't been very good at
identifying who that is so in the UK for
example all women get offered mammograms
when they turn 50.
nice the the body that puts out clinical
guidelines recommends that women of a
certain level of risk also have
mammograms during their 40s
one in five women twenty percent of
women fall into that group they are
completely invisible to us now and to
the NHS now whereas the technology that
we're developing and and partnering with
the NHS on that technology allows us to
identify these invisible high-risk
people and you can get them into
prevention programs earlier you can get
them into screening programs earlier and
you can get them into treatment programs
earlier and everyone agrees that
catching disease early or indeed
stomping it all together is a much much
better thing it's better for the
individuals obviously but it's better
for the Healthcare Systems because it's
much more expensive if you wait until
disease is well developed and try and
treat it than if you catch it early so
what's been the Tipping Point because
I've you know been in this field for
quite some time and at the very early
stages people quite dismissive about the
the contribution these polygenic risk
factors would play into the overall
picture you know it was a it was a few
percent but from what you're saying now
some of them actually when they start
adding them all up they make a big
difference to your risk of disease huge
huge difference
um so in so we currently estimate risk
for heart disease uh in GPS practices
they have a tool that combines your age
your sex your blood pressure your BMI
and so on and estimate risk
actually the genetic component of Risk
by itself which we've we've just learned
Thomas how to measure that's what the
big change has been
um that change by itself is about 40 of
uh the risks that we currently capture
for breast cancer this polygenic risk uh
the million places in in a woman's
genome that's the single largest
risk factor indeed if I were to predict
breast cancer risk and I know only that
and you know every other risk factor
that's ever been associated with breast
cancer I'll do much better than you if
you know all of those risk factors and
the genetic component we can now measure
you'll do a tiny tiny bit better than me
so for some diseases it's the critical
risk factor it allows us to identify
people much earlier in their life before
the symptoms of disease develop in order
to get them into screening programs or
prevention programs
but you're finding out some really
useful information I guess when you
if I went to my GP with one of your
reports um and they hate Dr Google
already if I came in holding one of your
reports saying look I've been told all
these all these letters in my my genome
put me at a higher risk of of prostate
cancer or or whatever and the GPS
disconnect I've got a waiting list
here's Monday morning I'm I'm really
busy with people who are sick how are
they going to incorporate what you're
telling the NHS into into their
consultation yeah great question
um and and
partly for that reason we don't offer a
report to you we work with the GP so
we've just done a trial um in the north
of England with GPS in adding the
genetic component of risk they're saying
we can now measure to the standard risk
predictor they do so we did a trial of
almost a thousand people in 12 GP
practices and it was all about checking
does this fit in with GPU workloads they
are massively overstretched the last
thing they want or indeed we want is
something that just won't work in
practice and that's what the trial was
about we measured the genetic component
of risk we've had it back to the GP not
to the patient and the GP could use that
in their conversations with the patient
the GPS loved it 99 of people said they
found it helpful and 94 said they could
understand it so they had been a worry
about how this would land on individuals
and in 13 of cases uh one in seven or so
the GP changed their management having
got the extra information about the
patient so I think it's about you're
absolutely right for this to work in
practice
it has to actually fit in with workflows
and that's something we're very focused
on Harris have you come against
resistance within the hospital to the
use of artificial intelligence
um
I wouldn't call it resistance I think
there is
um robust challenge
um and I think a lot of it's relatively
Fair
um what we had say a decade ago when we
had the first sort of influx of digital
Health Technologies and particularly Ai
and Technologies was a real lack of
clinical evidence just because something
does something cool or or technically
well doesn't mean it's useful to the
patient and and rightly so there are a
lot of misfires and and in fact a lot of
that was inherited from mammography
screening and clinical decision support
systems in the early 2000s and so we
sort of learned those lessons and there
was a lot of investment in running
clinical trials with AI Technologies
digital clinical trials which we
fashioned them now
and and as long as there's sufficient
evidence there's actually been quite
good adoption and everybody recognizes
the need for these tools in order to
make us more productive more safe and
more clinically effective
um
but that doesn't mean the conversation
is done it's an ongoing conversation
particularly as our Ambitions in terms
of what the technology could do grows
because actually
um what we're able to achieve with
artificial intelligence is can be quite
exciting at the moment it's it's
relatively resigned to you know
restricted tasks like interpreting MRI
scans or interpreting CT images
um but we can have end-to-end clinical
decision making where you're integrating
genetic data Imaging data and even
surgical outcomes to then decide how
this patient will be cared for in the
community and then obviously to to reach
that ambition the conversation needs to
grow and become richer not just with
staff but obviously the public
anyways the um the the operating theater
is changing quite rapidly it's it's not
just about people huddled around a
patient anymore you often find a
surgical robot in the corner or VR real
a technology that such as as you use
it's becoming really smart isn't it are
there some people are better some
surgeons who are better at
sticking with that change keeping pace
and sort of using it to its best
and that's an excellent question
um I think with with all change you have
people that are able to adopt the change
quite quickly and move on with it but a
particular issue with Health Care is at
the end of the day you know we're
dealing with people we're dealing with
people's lives and whilst Tech offers a
lot of benefits in terms of how we're
able to help people it does pose a
number of challenges as well and as
doctors and Healthcare professionals you
need to be cognizant of that so it's not
always the right thing to do is not
always taking the latest tech and using
the latest robots that's certainly not
the case what we need to get better at
and a lot of people have done that is to
be able to understand probability better
we have a lot more information at our
hands and certainly the patients do as
well you know I tell this virtually to
all my patients please don't console
Google before you come and see me and
almost everybody does it's just the way
life works so you need to start off by
debunking a lot of the information they
collect from Google and then talk about
the thing as it pertains to them and
we've spoken about personalized element
to it so Tech does provide that balance
where there's huge gains to be made but
how we adopt it particularly in
sensitive areas such as healthcare does
need to be managed very carefully and
that's really where Healthcare
professionals need to understand and be
trained in these techniques and
understand what these challenges are do
you think there's equal access to this
kind of medical technology globally I
mean for example the the twins that you
successfully separated and that was only
because of the charity that that you
founded Gemini Gemini and twin untwined
um
it is a problem isn't it this technology
doesn't come cheap sure I mean that's
that's always been the question you know
where you've had you've had places in
the world where things are innovated and
we get new discoveries and how that
dissemination happens but that question
is very much a societal question
as we said what we have we're extremely
fortunate here at Great Ormond Street
the hospital where I work it's one of
the leading Children's Hospitals with
UCL our academic Partners we've got the
tools and technology and the people and
the skill sets to do things that have
not been done before so we can innovate
in terms of these complex craniopaga
separations we have computer scientists
biomechanical Engineers whole teams of
these people and as you said it's not
just doctors and nurses anymore we
really are talking about diverse teams
that come together and just push the
boundaries well that's all well and good
that you've got it here how does that
help children in other parts of the
world so for us what we needed to do the
example we used was we've got all these
facilities in London we needed to set up
a charity that ensured that this
technology and these benefits were
accessible to any child and any set of
parents around the globe that needed it
that very much is a question for us as a
society not just Healthcare
professionals how do we ensure that what
we call Innovation does help the wider
audience and not just a select few
uh you too on the end this probably
applies to to both of you in that
artificial intelligence is only as good
as the data that you put in and there
have been problems in the past where uh
it it might work in in one group of of
patients but isn't so good at spotting
um things in another and the same with
with genetics you know risk scores might
be completely different in in different
different ethnic groups so how do you go
with the technology but not totally
believe in it in all cases
so from our perspective it's about
building into the the entire development
life cycle checks and balances that that
make sure that we are not exacerbating
the problems that exist in our data
because the reality is that our data is
biased right Healthcare and access to
healthcare is biased and what we don't
want to do is make those problems worse
by automating it and embedding that bias
into a machine or into an AI and so for
example
um as part of the London AI Center which
geyser Thomas is a founding member we
collaborate with academics and Industry
to develop artificial intelligence for
use in healthcare and before we
um collaborate on a particular project
we ask the project team to do a risk
assessment about the risk of bias that
their tool might produce and and how
they might mitigate that there's also
involvement from patient and public
members to make sure that the proposed
you know new pathway that they're
designing is one that would be amenable
to the public and so by building those
checks and balances in and peer review
allows us to mitigate it but obviously
even once it's developed and it's out in
the wild
so to speak we need to make sure that we
keep an eye on it and those things are
being monitored as they're being used
briefly just just come back on that as
well I mean how do you build the risk
scores to to apply properly to everybody
in the population yeah great it's a
great and really really important
question
um broadly the answer is the same you
make sure you check it widely so the
tool we used with GPS we had validated
in people of many different ancestries
because there can be issues we also put
a lot of effort so the answer is you
check it but also we put a lot of effort
into the algorithms to make sure that we
can be as clever as possible for people
from parts of the world where there's
currently a bit less data and that's
often the case for people outside
European perfect populations has anybody
got any questions that you'd like to put
to the panel it's a great opportunity
you've got three experts in the field
yes
in about you don't have a multicultural
samples how that which technique do you
use to make that data set balance
because I guess most of the time you
have an imbalance and from then you
build your prediction so what do you use
to being able to simulate or create an
up sampling or thumb sampling when you
don't have I mean a sample of a I'm
Latin American for example probably in
London there is no many samples of that
that's a great question so there's a
couple of standard techniques that you
would use to enrich essentially your
data set so if there's a particular
ethnicity or some other subgroup that is
that is underrepresented in your data
you can just enrich your data set so you
just go and find more of those people
and obviously in some cases that's not
feasible and so we're beginning to use a
lot more synthetic data where
essentially what we do is we learn about
say South Americans and we're able to
generate fake versions of that data that
is representative of that population and
but what it makes sure what it makes
sure is that once we train an algorithm
it's not biased against that
underrepresented data set
even when that fails there are instances
where an algorithm just isn't going to
perform well on a certain population and
that has always happened say for example
with drugs we just have to be
transparent about it and be very clear
that this can only be used in certain
circumstances with certain safeguards in
place
yes gently just wait for the mic yeah
just a gentleman here
thanks um so as the sort of predictive
power of AI Grows Where were the
accountability lie if there was a
mistake so would it be with the program
would it be with the doctor sort of
where would that accountability line who
would take accountability that's a great
question uh it's a great question
um one guy I get asked a lot um almost
always with the doctor
um especially in the near term where
these tools are actually acting as a
decision support they're never the final
decision maker they're always assisting
the clinician and making the decision
um but there there need to be checks and
balances on both sides so it's not all
on the doctor's shoulder we make sure
that the the manufacturing of these
tools are done in line with
International standards and best
practices and that there are ways to
escalate any errors or mistakes or poor
performance to the manufacturer But
ultimately you're taken care of by your
doctor and they've got your best
interest at heart to agree
um yes absolutely I think when you look
at
human interaction human interaction by
and large is not contractual based it's
based on trust
and that's trust between two humans be
that a patient a doctor a patient at a
nurse and I think we're a long long way
away from that trust between a machine
and a human
data I mean particularly Peter I mean
what happens if insurance companies get
a hold of the kind of information that
you're able to provide about our
blueprint
yeah and it's another really good
question and and one that comes up a lot
um
I personally I think that would be a bad
thing and actually I think that's an
issue for society Society can say to
insurance companies here are the rules
under which here's the kind of
information you're allowed to use and
here's the kind of information that
you're not allowed to use so some years
ago we had the situation where in car
insurance for young men was much more
expensive than car insurance for young
women because they had rather more
accidents as though it sort of made
sense and then there was a change I
think in the EU which said you couldn't
discriminate so insurers took that on
board and they still offer they used to
make money on car insurance in the old
world and they make money in the new
world where they have to have the same
premiums for young men and young women
insurance companies can make a living
and and we tell them what the rules are
and I think as societies we just have to
be proactive there so in the UK for
example
um it's already the case that insurers
don't and can't use genetic information
in setting premiums
um that kind of thing I think we should
in some countries it's enshrined in law
in other countries it's a code of
practice I I think that stuff's really
important but it's about Society saying
here's what you're allowed to use and
here's what you're not allowed to use
anybody else
over there
hi there thank you for your talk it's
been really interesting
um a couple of questions do spring to
mind though uh firstly
um with anything with new technology
um what you've said has all been very
rational and very reasoned but let's be
blunt a lot of people are not rational
or reasoned particularly over things
they don't understand
particularly around technology I think
as a lot of people worried about you
know like I've seen something I've seen
in Black Mirror or Terminator and
equally as well there is a a lot of
people been quite scared about health as
we've seen with the covered pandemic so
my question really is is that
what ways
can you reassure patients that they will
be safe and it's you know this is
something that it's you know on one
level can be answered with the head but
it also needs to be answered through the
heart as well in that sense
who wants to take that out
sure
Health Care as it stands at the moment
and for the foreseeable future will be
human to human interaction
so I think that's where the safety
blanket for the patient comes from the
issue is more at our end whereas
Healthcare Providers we're faced with a
whole lot of new technology a whole lot
of new data new algorithms and it's
trying to decipher which are the best
ways forward which are the and what we
need to get better at is managing
probabilities
and that's where data comes in that's
where data scientists come in in terms
of guiding our algorithms but it's an
ongoing Journey
um
the focus has to be on that relationship
between the doctor and the patient I
think that's
historically traditionally being the
Crux of healthcare now I think that will
continue setting in our lifetimes
very fast away from this idea of the
family doctor though is it are you
adamant the machines should not get in
the way of that relationship the
machines should augment that
relationship but that relationship is
fundamental Iris I interrupted you you
know this one I was just going to add a
I completely agree with with what away
says but I also think that in order to
achieve the ambition that that we all
have when it comes to integrating
technology and and importantly taking
along the population with us we need to
change how we engage the population when
we talk about innovating in the
Healthcare System I think we've been
really bad at being transparent
historically and but potentially it's
because of that paternalistic approach
with the family doctor and and I think a
radical transparency is going to be the
only way forward because there's too
much stuff happening there's too much
stuff to get educated about and informed
about forget about the patient for for
us Healthcare professionals there's too
many things to to learn how to
communicate and I think we just need to
be more open about the the stuff that
we've implemented the stuff that we're
evaluating the stuff that we're
researching so there you can see that it
doesn't just show up all of a sudden in
your NHS app you've actually seen it
evolve from the very beginning when it
was an academic idea to now as part of
your post natal checkups for example
look thank you so much all three of you
it's been absolutely fascinating to hear
three people who are really seizing the
opportunities of Technology but also
seeing the potential pitfalls and trying
to make sure that the technology is
being used in the most appropriate way
so thank you very much for all three
[Applause]